Monday Monday Brennan what's up buddy
I'm just glad to be alive
I yeah dude my bet made it back from
Mexico well and hurricane
Irma could have reached you there but I
guess you weren't in the eye of the
storm but now in Kabul though in Kabul
did they had a hurricane before so a lot
of stuff was shut down in in the
hurricane that hit what was it called
New Orleans that basically Hurricane
Katrina because it was it was yeah it
was below there's a lot more global OC
other below yeah there was a radio I did
a really disturbing thing about how in
the hospitals when the people who
couldn't move well on the top floors and
they couldn't get them down game on you
had to leave them yeah yeah they think
that some of the nurses euthanize them
yeah because they have really tough but
you know some of the doctors were like I
can't leave you up here I can't leave
you to die like this grabbing stuff or
just dying you know what pissed me off
is they were shown how you know
everyone's trying to get out and get
fresh water and gases you know gas for
the cars to get out of town they hiked
up the prices Oh pieces of [ __ ] so for
couching for bottle you know for 12 pack
water was like $75 for back of water
yeah everyone's like America's sticks
together it's like you [ __ ] yeah then
that's illegal too price gouging is
illegal in that situation how about it
was so bad the cops you know once once
it started to hit the cops can't answer
calls they say you're on your own they
try to get [ __ ] for 911 they tried to do
the price gouging thing and what kind of
terrible people do that you [ __ ] get
caught doing that we will Prosecco
horrible is that full extent law it's
just taking backs super scumbags
yeah how about when I was in Cabo the
place where we stayed at Rogan sends me
this article goes be careful bro which I
didn't mean since he goes be careful bro
and literally at the resort I was
staying at there was a shooting there
two weeks before I got there on the
exact beach I was on what I think from
cartel members and they went to the
beach shot four people kill them but
then the people around him
bullets or other people died and like
why thoughts you know so they going
there well yeah I just got this anyone
here yeah so so I go there right I'm
there
yeah and so I'm there and I was asking
like what's the deal with cartel stuff
and they said what's going on is and
this is from the locos locals they were
saying they're crazy Loeb local locals
they were saying that El Chapo sons are
there and now they're and they're having
a problem with these other people and
they don't [ __ ] with tourists really but
what happened here and this is crazy the
guy the resort was telling us is these
kids they're 8 to 18 year olds a 19 on a
20 year old run Instagram and they're
staying at this resort they're on in the
whatever had a bunch of money they're
pretending that they're part of the
cartel and they're cartel members
they're talking all this [ __ ]
so I'll chop the sons like oh really and
it's because their post on Instagram
where they were at senta's he's
Santoro's su carro cigar service acharya
set the servants say what that means
that the hitman no sicarios because
Sicarius yeah so it means servants so
they sent them down there murdered him I
was like what the [ __ ] the guy was
saying that it's going out which is
crazy
yeah it meant ah horrible right Sicario
um yes so they sent them and that's
what's going on down there like you
really have much to worry about
you've seen a mile inland now though in
Cabo is where like tersh go to get drugs
and now taxes won't go up there I was
like what the [ __ ]
I kept mass in that resort yeah got my
ass in that resort that's right that's
what I'll do yeah yeah mm-hmm go on
they're like going on with the extended
family mmm stay there yeah over Aden I
would agree with you on that I were a
great bin there in there twice I've been
there before I just it's hard for me to
relax man I'm not good at vacations I
don't need a vacation for anything
really it's just I'm not gonna like be a
guy Tony Jefferies like a [ __ ] moved
it made people people love it some
people look but I'm always super wary of
friends I have that
always go on vacations why see you when
I know people at consecrations what are
you running from man
well like my whole like fingers are so
good how sometimes your job is just what
you have to do and make you live for
vacations but or other times you know
it's a time to be spend time with the
family and be alone and not having
anything to do yeah reset yeah I'm not
that good of a keishon I must have met
now I was born yeah well you were kind
of rewarded I'm the narcos stuff I
wanted to give you a I wanted to say
something to you and look you in the eye
wanna see congratulations
goddamnit you got engaged I'm so happy
for you and I'm I'm emotional hug you in
it with people who it's alright die so I
feel like guys feel like they have to
say girls are more excited yeah well I
said I made you a little video with the
Fabrizio curry I wanted your girls funny
yeah yeah but you know what I mean so I
wanted to make your video but yeah I
mean I'm not gonna go hey buddy
congratulations huh yeah it's your dad
it's kinda like it's kind of a room of a
death but it's also like ah like you
just like I get it yeah with guys it's
different
I've never been a huge believer in
marriage and what it stands right I've
never even known yeah I've never had
like them divorce family and I just I
just never really believed in the
structure of marriage I think having a
kid is by far bigger binding contract
than any government paperwork yeah like
when you have a kid I don't care if you
hate each other whatever you're never
leave in a kid's life but you're it's
not that but you and that mother
connected for life or anyway another
whether you hate each other not you are
forced to do a mother of your child not
because there's a government contract so
to me that was a bigger deal but the
game changer for me I've never really
wanted to get married I you know that I
never it's it's strange to me though the
whole structure of it and getting down
on the knee felt like James like me lady
hey and there's my bum knee my [ __ ] back
then you know it's old-school man it's
very funny I didn't get down on my knees
you got that
yeah you gotta do it fly key right
otherwise I'm like what the [ __ ] that's
good but um yeah the the big difference
for me is kids Tigers starting to go to
preschools and in LA people in like this
is ridiculous but in LA preschools it's
so competitive and you got to start them
and a certain preschool to get into
elementary school to get in middle
school Ian price it's a whole system
here and it's stupid competitive so we
went to all these preschools and most
dads aren't there it's just the moms and
the kids but I decided to go definitely
checking the [ __ ] out swish when it
comes to sports and diet and stuff like
that so I go there and all the moms all
have rings and they look they didn't
weren't taking Joe as serious on the cow
hell no these [ __ ] are these Sears
they treat her a little different and
then so there was that and then I don't
want my son growing up back yo what's
wrong with my mom why don't you have a
ring man you know like I don't want him
so those were the big it's always been a
a social institution and that pressure
is very real and she feels I never felt
pressure no but women will and
especially in that so she Latin yes
Latin women yes but I never it to me
it's so strange like let's say you know
the big thing there's the prenuptial
agreement stuff like that but you know
like like let's say if a relationship
doesn't work out you shouldn't get half
my [ __ ]
well I'm in California in California you
this is what I know of the divorce laws
I believe this is the case you keep what
you came to the marriage with but
whatever you accumulated during the
marriage you split in half however that
can also be subject to negotiation if
you haven't been married for like seven
years
once you've married seven years or ten
years I think it's ten that's again to
him here you're you're done yeah yeah
you're just gonna I'm not even worried
about that and I get that's the law I
can't change thing about them and I have
no issues with any of that stuff I don't
care about the stuff I understand it's a
little weird like I didn't worked out
no one's it's big it's so jasmine
however old-school it's very old-school
but in India they just passed a law I
think was in India where basically if
you were a if you were a Muslim Indian
man and you were to say I divorce you I
divorce you I
divorce you you said yeah and not only
what at least now I know not only is
that binding now is that legally binding
but he gets you he gets all the property
and he gets the kids so this was a lot
that's [ __ ] up well but but let's
today but it was in he was really late
to the game because that was very much
the case in a lot of the Arab world for
a long time now they've passed laws
since then of create productions say
they're doing things exactly right there
well but even for them that became even
like too much they're like you can't
just divorce because a woman would be on
the guys doing on email via Skype and
crazy [ __ ] no I'm not saying that yeah
and I I don't care about getting half my
stuff I'm just saying the whole concept
of it's a little old-school yes I agree
and to begin to me it does it's
obviously a super important for I feel
like maybe more important for females
than his males
I would agree socially yeah but you know
they've done a lot of like the debate
has always been about whether or not
monogamy and marriage of because every
culture every literally every culture
for the most part recognizes a type of
marriage a union between a man and a
woman yeah and there's a ceremony
typically there's and there's a there's
a bonding sort of agreement right yeah
but but the question is actually there
have been societies that have shared
children not they're not very numerous
but they've sort of shared actually by
the village yeah they're raised by the
village that idea well the problem is
the problem is that you know it there is
this natural like inclination to pass
your genes on as a human being and you
get jealous and you you're protective of
that unit right so that's your boy yeah
okay and that boy even looks like you so
they even say that later they they say
children will resemble their father when
they're very little and that's
biologically so the father doesn't kill
the child just really so the woman goes
back in the gestation you know yeah well
that's what Lions do that's what a lot
of animals do yeah when the lion comes
and goes oh these are kids yeah gotta
kill them all kill them cuz now you
growth but killing kids stop them
Nursing got a killer kids I get back up
yeah give a dick wet yeah and then they
they so new and I'm gonna rape you
that's Game of Thrones still correct
you've killed all the boys correct girl
that's right that's right so that was
always back in the day other murder the
sure I call those the good old days now
let me fin me to having explained again
I know I keep referring game of thrones
but I watch down like like when there
are negotiations in the the small man
with his name the [ __ ]
yeah the dwarf he come the dwarf in the
shop it's Targaryen Targaryen yeah when
there's negotiating these like now
hopefully you will take my offer and
acceleration they just bring those three
hot chicks yeah and like there's those
[ __ ] houses and yeah it was pretty good
promise if you got I mean if you got
syphilis and things like that it wasn't
really I would do you I'm just saying
like they don't I mean I know what
you're saying but you can go the bunny
ranch in Reno here because I'm also woke
up tied sure but there am i right like
that day yeah they didn't oh yeah that's
a kill each other I for what I didn't
have problems yeah and the bushes and
yeah or maybe not or maybe they had
their one baby was awesome maybe it was
awesome it was clean and now there's no
way it was clean well do you know that
people from what Pepsodent okay look up
perhaps event which was this amazing
invention and I was 1915 in this country
because for the most part people didn't
really brush their teeth the country in
the nineteen like after before 1915 it
was pretty rare to actually brush your
teeth and pence for us well flora didn't
come along until I think what changed
again for changed the gate because the
the water and Denver yes yes something
like that but but for the most part
Pepsodent was the chemist put a little
peppermint in it because it made
people's mouths feel clean and it took
an amazing
but people back you just had [ __ ] dragon
baby they didn't really brush their
teeth
so if sona's bad breath now go your
breath smells like Khaleesi you you said
you have police you drive yeah yeah but
you know remember
dental hygiene dental hygiene
and in fact the idea that you cleaned
your teeth was actually not something
you did you just lost your [ __ ] teeth
my grandma she knows she's born raised
in England Wow grew up eating it she
lost all her teeth at 26 yes sir well
all of the joke so recently I'm sorry to
all our wonderful British fans was that
if you had the teeth in Britain were
never really that good in comparison now
it's good my blood freedom buddy made a
joke he goes I went to end in England
well I can talk about teeth you could
throw an apple at these peoples face and
it would stick oh now it's good though
yeah no it's good it's like an old joke
now when I was in I'm going to tell you
a story when I was in England I did some
stand-up and I was at my friend's farm
our boy Joey and there was a a woman who
was a farmhand there and I had done some
stand-up for his whole his bank and it
didn't go well at all awesome and I was
American your smile mm-hmm Oh disaster
yes in a tent outside with a bad mic it
was great yeah it was yeah
but more lonely oh yeah oh well when I
say crickets British people looking at
me like [ __ ] you who's this [ __ ]
terrible American I was doing who's the
guy worst teeth than a bad comedy well
that yeah well well well however however
there was a young lady there who took a
shine to me and I it was dark and I was
looking at she had she was our horse
back she was looking at you like a wine
gums she worked in the stables and she
had she had a tight pair of jeans and I
was like this girl's got a great body
well she had a she had a great dig nope
no and calluses all over no no her but
she motorbikes your dick later sir the
Persian carpet she no we I took care of
business but hurt in that horse stable
her teeth were were if there was a sound
effect her teeth were like I was like is
somebody speeding up the camera her
teeth are all like she open her mouth
like a mako shark like that like
something that like like spins or you
could put things in it
and it's just a grinder I've never seen
teeth like really a disaster and
yelloweye su-sure a whole disaster do
you think I gave a [ __ ] does she get him
on get him on your piece though she got
him on my piece they're wrong they were
sharp they were they were it was very
responsible of me III looked my dick
looked like it's the least you could do
after Bonnie yeah it looked like I saw
easy to do and if I represent America of
piranhas yeah the least you could do to
represent a carrots and peace are down
had to piece her down calm dingo well
cool check out this dick yo check out my
white red and blue dick yeah well now
it's very red because of those teeth
sharp those ivories won't proud of you
for sticking it out thanks buddy thanks
buddy
yeah she looks like Chucky the doll oh
sure she had sharp teeth oh thank you
file those things down how about in Cabo
everyone our boy Todd and my brother
everyone I talk to you like you got to
go to floor of farms get off get off the
resort go to Flora farm
all right if you tell me to botanical
garden I'm gonna freak out bro are you
gonna floor farms I'm in Mexico all
right Ellie has the best food in the
world I don't need to go to floor farms
where it's owned by is basically a
[ __ ] cult of white people farm all
organic all white people I get there
like oh [ __ ] no Mexican food no what no
Mexicans all why people farm they have
organic food grown foods okay I get
pizza and my girl had like a turkey sale
they grow their own food there yeah and
then they sell and then after they give
us a pitch on basically a timeshare
would you love to take a walk around the
farm and what we do is we sell these and
then you have your own farm out front oh
yeah really in Cabo so with them I was
like how dare you when some Cabo melon
it was just all it was just like it was
like a little getaway for white people
so strange man yeah getting back to the
land yeah exactly
I understand not for me man no no if I
want when I got a mixer I want Mexican
food yeah how was the food in Cabo just
okay
good well there's good there's good fist
there's good like do you know where
you're staying
I don't I know I'm going with my
extended extended family it's gonna be
about 35 of us oh wow and I am it's
gonna be during New Year's I am NOT
looking forward to this I tried to back
out make sure my mother sister
spookified at least don't please don't
back I'll book us a fun and kid what's
the date I already turned out I'm just
doing tours
that'd be gracious to a tour in life do
you know FaceTime in you know what the
nice thing was in Mexico is out there
you know they're not she's trying to
grow the UFC brand do you see paper you
and they have a channel just for it's
something UFC fight some Mexican name
but there's no paper use out there
so everything's free Wow so like oh you
have to watch the whole card for free
they'd watch
I saw everything the HBO boxing with
chocolate not bad that's a real bummer I
but you I got to see everything the
fights were I enjoyed the fights I
thought it was a horrible card well what
did you think when you say enjoy be what
did you enjoy about so here's I thought
I really would you watching I set the
stage for me
I watched him out watch it house by
yourself okay that's best so what I
really enjoyed actually and and I'll
make up you tell me what you think I I
don't straight to main event right now
we can go straight to main event
I mean well say when you say enjoyed the
fights like what did you enjoy if you
look at all the fights Neil Magny got
yeah I mean throw a punch
what's the wrong way on the head on yeah
what's the wrong way just a world-class
guy no it's Neil Magny should not be he
he's very good he's beat some great guys
when it comes to work glasses you too he
that's just not for him say that's his
Achilles heel ha look at Demian Maia
look at dos Anjos like they ate his ass
on the ground he's lost on his feet
wrestling he's a mid-level purple belt
jiu-jitsu which at that level the top
six top ten you need eight the [ __ ] up
if they have a good ground game yes so
we saw that so that wasn't a fight right
and then Gilbert Melendez why what was
fun George watching out tough
that doesn't do it for me and I thought
your how tough your so-so journey
Stevens fight no wonder I did
he's find one like Melendez yeah and
what the decision and Melendez kept him
falling down from his leg was so [ __ ]
up they should have stopped the fight
but Melendez so goddamn tough he didn't
want to sound tough yes things with one
leg and I know it sounds like I'm hating
but I was just like I had a one like
Steve in a skill level man it looked
like it was really I mean maybe more who
for for Jeremy Stephens I thought you
look great it's rough to tell ya you're
Frank died with one leg yeah so what's
skill well I did Gilbert like changing
from South Father
not really you can't change yeah so you
get to leave his lead leg out there to
kick it fall into this and this new the
picture has a new low kick no its legs
like [ __ ]
yeah just but to me like that that
wasn't fun for me to watch like I know
how tough Gil is I don't need a
demonstration for three rounds of aged
it doesn't do anything for me
God it was a great win for Jeremy
Stephens but it wasn't a fight right so
then then what other fights you know
Sophia Latifi versed Pedro yeah I like I
enjoyed the main card a lot that's what
we cover in the main code no I mean I
enjoyed the main event I thought Amanda
Nunez in Valentino Valentin or hey there
striking is so to me look so high level
it just looked so technical and I loved
watching it I really did
Valentina Shevchenko is so what so what
do you think that I thought it was real
first so so so for me I couldn't figure
out who was actually ahead in the car I
thought I thought that at the end of the
day it was so close the until until the
Valentina's tried to throw that headlock
made a mistake Amanda took her back and
then a man who took her down so in the
field for that just for that I would
have given I would have edged it out to
a man in a yes right there be right but
they were both so good like you're
talking about like I'm gonna say I
almost wanted to talk about it on like
it's like you're talking about we talked
about sexism we talked about feminism
and stuff like that dude
you're talking about two women who are
on such a level on such a technical
level as fight
and it's riveting and I would even
suggest with the exception of generic
that female fighting is has never been
in a lot of ways this exciting female
boxing I can't really name a female
boxer all due respect there's some great
one there's one right MMA has got is
this is a new sport for women it's as
competitive as women's tennis or you
know as anything else disagree be really
not this is why it's competitive and
hear me I like women's fighting a man in
una Shevchenko I agree with you
Shevchenko cannot expect to win a fight
by just counter punching all fight long
again her octagon control was awful
Amanda Nunez if I Manning is didn't
pressure the fight you don't have a
fight so Shevchenko can't win a fight by
always answering second that make sense
yeah she Oh Hannah pond she only
responded and you can be a counter
puncher but sometimes you have to press
the action or throw shots to land like
kicks but if a man Nunez does not
approach her does not is not the
aggressor you don't have a fight at all
so in that fight she really didn't lay
anything significant she lent some shots
she and you know but again I was looking
at the rounds ago listen alright I give
a manna Nunez not not lots going on and
no one playing in a lot she has octagon
control aggression control there's no
fight if she's not if a man is not
pressing the action right when I say
press action Amanda wasn't thrown much
either it wasn't that it was in a great
fight at all their last fight was much
better men a man in this is much better
fights
Amanda Nunez you know there you could
argue that she's the best female fighter
of all time at 135 yeah she's beat me
argument Ronda Rousey Shevchenko twice
and shared why I said baby should be
Duran Amin as well yeah so you look at
you on paper she's probably the best of
all kind here so that fight wasn't great
but again I would give a man around
she's the champ
she's aggressor Achtung control not a
whole lot of action going on what really
sticks out to your point the takedown
yeah when chef Jenny went for that
takedown and then you know then Amanda
had her back had back control and then
the the huge takedown the fifth round
and then you know chef Schenker's laying
some shots from her back but not doing
much so I mean it controlled those
rounds I give the fight to mana close
edge
no one got robbed chef jayke oh I'm not
trying to see the third time I guess I
guess well this is my point sure when
you say it's as high level as tennis
it's not because those girls playing
tents have been doing it for how long
since there were seven since they're
seven how many tennis players are in the
world how many many many men worldwide
so in again this is just where at it's
not a knock on female fighting but
female fighting has been around that
long that oh maybe three years four
years you know me let's say six years
yeah 86 years yeah but maybe a little
longer I'm saying as far as mainstream
being getting notoriety getting
attention let's say six years to play it
safe here six years so if you have a
daughter and she's 18 and wants to be a
fighter chance for making UFC as a
female fighter she me six and o7o it's
probably gonna make it so the level of
talent isn't that great right they you
you know you have your you have your
gather your talent pool so you have
Shevchenko who's 16-time world champion
muy Thai she's been do it for every of
Holly Holm you know you have Rhonda with
a judo background Amanda knows Raja -
and you know just with her background
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu stuff like that but
there's just not there's not a deep pool
yes so right you know Shevchenko versus
Amanda knows it's the most technical
fight we've seen out of women a long
time that's what I his Amanda had so I
mean Rhonda had such an advanced French
Jew but then the game kata and then
she's not as for me but yeah to say it's
as good as tennis women's soccer even
women's basketball or any of that stuff
swimming gymnastics it's just not yet
however wouldn't you say that the tip
and I don't know but but would you say
that the fight the actual fight we
haven't seen that level of striking just
just distance counter
head movement you know all of that you
Lana verse Claudia go deja was a better
fight right because because you wanna
you wanna wanna as far as mixed martial
arts is a better striker than shift
change she's amazing although I think
Shevchenko beat her when they fought
outside because she was bigger - yeah
but still I think for my money Yohan is
the best strike in the earth I would
agree with you on that and she just had
over heals better than everyone but
again who she fighting as far as
comparables in that striking background
what about what about amendments been
around
you even look at men like I'll watch
like if when you watch triple G canal oh
this weekend right when you watch it
this weekend the level of striking that
fight and then you go back to UFC fight
those guys have going but someone can
only been striking for four or five
years it's true yeah and but what I'm
saying you can tell I'm sorry and you
can tell you can tell yeah you can tell
yo you see a guy like a lot of times she
a guy who might have c6 and O in his
background I don't know I might be
arresting or something those heavy
weights this weekend yeah the guy he
pull back like this do you think canal
or tripled you never fighting since
there are seven however wouldn't you say
I feel like as I watch I'm trying to
give another example of this
well even Jeremy Stephens even though
he's fighting Gilbert who was injured
but I feel like the striking game for
all of these guys every six months gets
out gets higher level yeah that's right
and I think you're seeing a lot of
that's a great point and I think you're
seeing a lot of guys who aren't adapting
getting left behind yes I listen Gil's
been around for a long time
Jeremy Stevens isn't a Conor McGregor
wonderboy Thompson but Jeremy Stephens
like oh you're gonna have a white stance
like a boxer you think you're like
you've been doing that for ten years and
that's all you're either wrestling or
boxing I'm just gonna kick your leg cuz
you're like right there I'm making a
kicker but I have that that ability to
kick yeah so guys that in camps that
aren't making those adjustments or
getting left in the dust because when
you think about especially from from
really from 185 not fair from 170 down
look at all the champs name one champ
who's just doing boxing arrest now none
of them it's not 170 170 so you got
Woodley right but so he got one boy he's
making ways yeah guys like Jorge Maas
Vidale and then at 55 we get 55 Conor
Tony Kevin Lee could be these guys they
mix it all well forty five max Holloway
yeah a game-changer 35 you got TJ
Dillashaw at Cody garb and those guys do
everything well and then you got Mighty
Mouse so guys that like and there's not
enough enough depth at 85 light
heavyweight heavyweight you can get away
with doing that stuff steep
just boxing wrestling light-heavyweight
you got DC just boxing wrestling because
they're all older but that you can see
where the game's evolving yeah to your
point with these lighter weight classes
diet like mats Holly does it all
karma Gege does it all I mean Tony first
he's doesn't raise II shoveling does it
all yeah these guys are you know they're
they're dynamic yeah but in that's
you're gonna see that really classic
example of slowly trickles down as the
heavier because the heavier weight class
is always it takes forever how much
depth there's not a lot of big guys out
there so it takes a while to the advance
but you're gonna get some freak that
looks like Anthony Joshua or that looks
like LeBron James who's like how much I
fighting any good at everything
dominates like you're John Jones but
without the P DS yeah that's very true
but that it's a good point but because
with Gill and you look at these guys
there comes a time where the can't the
game past very interesting to me to that
Gill who's a veteran and stuff and that
comes from a camp I guess it just didn't
dawn on them that whatever they get the
whole core it's been working the all the
more successful you got Nick Diaz Nate
Diaz Jake Shields Gilbert and I kick my
kick my leg whatever but but the game
again cuz you just got to keep going
nobody can take kicks to your lower leg
like that for a fight for sure bring up
a picture it feels like it's literally
all I mean this is that this is the new
kick to like these were ball goes low
one walk or the meat is against team
it's really isn't that's not his forte
is kicking but God would you see this
way this from his wife who's also a
fighter
well yeah that's a that's just not a
good that's not a good time and I guess
it's not bone it's just all muscle
swelling muscle yeah like you you've had
these issues
how long is he is he limping weeks weeks
I was in a wheelchair after Gonzaga in a
[ __ ] wheelchair like with Michael
channeling he got kicked and it hit a
nerve that just turned his foot off like
you thought his foot was broken I was
like no literally he just kicked the
perfect nerve ending it turned my foot
off came back and then a player come
goddamnit taking a [ __ ] man
yes it's a [ __ ] it's why I
always wear my [ __ ] steel socks right
yeah I'm not no Helen I steal socks
brother but that fight I was like oh and
I was going back forth to people and I
you know not on Twitter but friends and
texting we had this group chatting it
just wasn't a great card it just use it
yeah and amanda has to have surgery now
on her sinuses and some other stuff you
guys yeah so she's out to at least from
taking hits her for now she said she had
that chronic pain that's why she pulled
out in the fight before so amazing but
yeah the card was it you know I'm not
gonna blow that's for her what about a
man and Nunez going up to 45 and
fighting you know who know why would she
do it she can set the record at the the
bantamweight she can't yeah I think
that's a hard way for her to cut that 35
no no she's not big no she's not she's
not that big I was actually surprised
how kind of small she was because she
could say you don't think that would be
a 45 she's not fighting but why it
doesn't make sense she needs to keep
fighting and clean out the division and
then finest yeah who else is there
besides Valentina Shevchenko is that
good though there's some girls if you
bring up the vision there's there's some
girls I mean off the Giuliani opinio got
you know submitted by Shevchenko but if
she gets a win that's a big one
Duran amis back at 35 mm-hmm Holly Holm
home but Holly Holm suppose fight cyborg
but you got pena yep Raquel Pennington
Ronnie still out there huh that's
strange and then you know hopefully Kat
comes back retired right Rhonda she's
never ever he's here Friday I don't
think so
but it's very strange that they yeah I
think Holly and sideboards the fight
hopefully hopefully they get that done
but yeah though the card was whatever I
mean there's a fight this card this
weekend same night as [ __ ] Canela
triple G was the card Luke Rockhold
fighting home World Series yeah David
branch I didn't know until I saw a room
put fight week and I was a cat triple G
can Ellen I was like oh hell no
this is a tuna fight for for our boy
Luke well he's been out a while Dave
Dave branch number nine in the world and
he's a world champion light heavyweight
and middleweight and we'll say a few
ways Wow twenty-one three long Bart's
fighting oh let me see this we got
Thiago Alves fighting Michael parry
pears a monster yeah Paige probably
retire your boy Elvis Perry's a monster
scary scary man he is he a jujitsu guy I
can't remember he's everything yeah he's
a punch in your [ __ ] face I can guy
can you and then we got Lombard fighting
Smith hmm listen man it's the night of
triple G Canelo your god sakes
yeah I just can't I just can't I'll
record it I'm definitely gonna watch him
after that
I just can't how dare you yeah the same
night I'm excited about that fight what
are we doing for that fight no no go to
Frank's man you got to come to Frank's
it's gonna be in that just crowded field
ya know you'll have Pro boxers there
people who've not gonna be that's the
worst thing I know I watch at home in my
family come over to Frank I can't stand
it man we run has their two cents and
what guys should be doing and stuff
throw the jab more oh why is he not
jabbing ya when you fight a guy that you
got a fake look if you come I'm gonna do
that doors you got a fake bang that's
just general [ __ ] bop bop like you gotta
go the body more this listen we've gotta
go to the bot you listen when he go to
the book oh so that I can break so my
face is open
Frank you were in the purge too that
doesn't mean you can critique Canelo
Alvarez boxing he boxes dude yeah
Frank's just got back from actually in
Mexico where he was with Juan Marquez
yeah he's doing that show for I can't
wait to see that for Netflix yeah he
goes and finds all the fight gyms and
basically yeah it's cool show yeah yeah
same Charlie done history they did that
before that's great Frank could be great
because yeah that's great yeah and
they've got great [ __ ] photography an
amazing photographer cinematographer
like I'm amazing one camera the guy but
it's a cool show you guys watch that
fire my god it's the end of an era for
chocolatito how he's like 48 or
something the best of all time but you
know there's always debate on who he's
fighting stuff like that
you saw this kale right it's bad I
didn't see it he was out for like 5
minutes that's bad one from c3 Sacketts
or wrong day his cats a few Scouts
biggest cats of all time no [ __ ] he's
gonna night you ever seen oh geez any
beaten before everyone's like it was a
food thing I went fluke on peep this out
[ __ ] so that was the first one
[Applause]
oh god those Tigers the [ __ ] tabs
boom Felicitas playing with fire stay in
the pocket of that boy you see his wife
or his girlfriend afterwards yeah that's
so painful was it bad she just ran away
crying oh that's tough to watch man yeah
I was watching Hard Knocks last night
and it's the Tampa Bay Buccaneers so
there's the right first week of football
season yeah
and last night was the Hard Knocks it's
always a bummer cuz the last episodes
the cuts you know there's a veneer tell
but the the one quarterback latina
quarterback la la feu it's a something
Hawaiian but he play it usually Colorado
so I've saw him last year you know
they're really good good quarterback
even Tampa Bay Buccaneers and he's you
started off the fourth string
quarterback they only keep two and
Fitzgerald if you know football he's the
backup stuff his chance to make it or
not good but they're acting like he was
gonna make it and he's playing in the
last preseason game but he has when he
go in you gotta remember he's going in
with the third and fourth stringer old
line so he's in there show these this
wasn't that good or the protections are
awful it's way easier play defenses
third string than his office so he
literally just getting destroyed but
shows his mom a girl for like [ __ ] okay
here we go they yeah and he's like he's
going yo like these [ __ ] blast
geysers thank you and he throws up for
tryouts art with this know this real
pieces in gaming oh this is the last
game they're like if he does well he
might make the team and then he's like
and he's like all right boys he's like
be positive I love this guy
I think he's didn't go on and do good
things but Cheryl the guy with the beard
from Harvard sure it was the Jets nice
backup
yeah starters of societies so so they
show his name 6fo I think and he's a guy
boys this we just gotta get in there man
let's do the best we can and then you're
doof is helmet they rip it off he gets
turn around the other way and his no he
breaks his nose blood everywhere he pops
I guess is is my nose alright nice dough
linemen guys it's bleeding brown nose
all right man and he just got the
girlfriend like oh no mama girlfriend
like
Oh riced tough guy but to you then the
next day's cuts wait was this was this
Fitzgerald and this is C fo the CFO from
Fisher it's a monster I'm not I was like
this is my boyfriend Colorado
cell phone in him you think yeah
does the name give it away B yeah but
he's got he's not all Simone cuz that's
a big ass Apple no his mom's widest yeah
because Samoans don't have long necks
with Adam as hapless they don't have
neck so it's very different that's a
white guy necklace so that's what you
get that's what you get mom for not
being with a fellow Samoan you can't no
shooting all the moms white the dad some
well I thought I - way to go dad but
then you're not gonna have the height no
the Samoans are very tall sometimes some
of them can be six-foot they're [ __ ]
six for some of them are huge mmm
they're not neck is too long sir
he was a good quarterback sure he's a
very good athlete you know but still he
got bill he got [ __ ] a more Samoan in
there who's the first guy to get cut
that's tough they sat him down and and
that's it no no he had no he had picked
up off waivers from another team but
it's gonna be tough I mean took
quarterback stuffs job in the league but
it was rough to watch his family watch
it like oh my he's just getting eaten
alive by his defense women linebackers
he reached his injuries injury
settlement mmm Wow
that's his knee oh [ __ ] bout to get paid
son nice good for him [ __ ] yeah good for
him it's funny though [ __ ] yeah then
they got that and they make you know he
didn't throw a touchdown they took it
back but then the coach who's the first
one you cut just like well you're gonna
call for me you know it's not good
that's the worst okay you have what they
say to you and you not much just like
you know I appreciate the work yeah a
good hustle oh all right yeah good luck
with whatever else you okay I'm a good
vodcast [ __ ] be a comic see you later
you're gonna rue the day yeah silly
though silly yeah
I love Hard Knocks though I need to
watch it because I know I love it I
don't you would like you because like my
girl hates football she loves hard not
because the stories it shows you like
what they go through shows their
families yeah shows the relationship
with all the guys it's funny there's so
many things to watch did you watch to
watch narcos have you watched season
three I've been so balls to even Game of
Thrones I'm almost on season seven I
know I told you no what do you think
it's great yeah it's good I'm excited
for now it goes good stuff
I'm football season started and football
season sir I won't be watching any
football yeah it's just not your thing I
know sign up for your key both fighting
yeah I like football but no again yes
some tournaments Oh hold on how are you
guys MJ what'd you do this weekend go
ahead jump on my girl I'm at the Chuck's
today always I mean I didn't do anything
too interesting no just doing I saw it
oh I got I think it was the biggest
opening movie
it's WAP there it's the biggest of all
time damn I think like 137 it was the
biggest September release opening the
trailer beat records and like filmmaking
history I got to do with that because I
biased about it
the trailer is exactly like the original
one though that's what I want and
they're already making a prequel you
know that the other raid making another
one well they saw a agreement makes
sense
ah dude don't give it no spoiler alert
office I've seen the original so there's
an evil clown kids die
was it good though it was good it was
not what I expected the original is good
I heard I heard cuz my buddy perused it
one of the things if you were I lost so
much story like there's a lot of story
there's a lot like there's a real
development of the carrots how it was
the original the original it's out over
two hours long now there's a lot yeah I
feel like that pays off horror movie no
you can't do Strayhorn scared it pays
off because then when you see the clown
you want it more okay no cuz he gives
them the sailboat in the previews did
you go with a friend um I went last
night with a couple people we saw in
Inglewood and it was packed
you know what you tried to do more those
property it's nice because this day I'm
coming what are you talking about yeah
the Rams are making everything nice yeah
there's a lot of good problems
so you went to Inglewood yeah and we're
front row so I was like this the entire
city tickets it was just only tickets
yeah we are there like 25 minutes early
- I've got to see that movie yeah you
have to it's pretty good is it scary I
know I see I'd like to be like jumping I
want to be cringy like in my seat what
you like like it wasn't scary yeah I
haven't seen Annabelle yet good scary
those people know how to like get a rise
out of cops they have found up formula
okay we're good at it yeah you you you
like scary movies
my favorite type movie is really because
you get a little horny I don't know I
just like the stuff I don't like action
movies that does nothing for me not
scary movies actually movies do nothing
for me either scary movies like do the
scary stuff I like that [ __ ] I'll look
the guys sliding and shooting kekekekeke
it's a terrible movie play key key key
key key
Oh big guy muscle key key car I saw baby
driver Oh
were there guys dressed up as clowns in
that movie No
so I saw Sony's game go is a I forget
who posted it baby I guess I got to it
early and this [ __ ] the only
guy in the theater it was a clown with a
balloon dressed up sitting mid row no
the guy goes mother [ __ ] are you serious
so creepy what the [ __ ] well everyone
gets offended now chin and I were
looking at a video where these clowns
went on some talk show saying that it's
gonna ruin that their career and their
money yeah super weird
real clowns are worried it might ruin
their careers well first of all well
first of all your korean Fuhrer clown
let's not call it a career it's
definitely not a career but also it's
doing 17 who the [ __ ] is still doing
clown stuff and who's hiring these
Indies there's a sitcom a long time ago
I can remember where the guy is breaks
up the girl because the girls a
professional clown and she goes I just
don't think I could date a classy
because I can't not be a clown oh my
well see ya so you saw it you liked it
though you proved it I like it it wasn't
Gary though it wasn't scary they in my
opinion what scared to you though mmm I
think jumpsuits unexpected the unknown
so when all sudden there's like someone
that comes out of closet or total skiers
I like the cheap scares I like you know
yesterday chin what'd you do ah mom's
birthday so how old's mom I don't even
know she doesn't talk about it she
didn't talk about it free tough to tell
she might be 200 no idea Jesus always a
Galapagos tortoise
yeah you've no idea uh what no no date
though huh I can't I can't I I cannot
emphasize this enough chin so many
people damn ego chin is being the
biggest [ __ ] when it comes to tinder
no they say they're saying the but
they're they're saying that's how it
works and they're saying you shouldn't
get on tinder because tinder is about a
game of numbers yeah see how to go Jim's
looking for [ __ ] Cinderella on tinder
Cinderella innominate you can have this
whole thing start with a slump-buster
yeah you're looking for wifey I want you
to mess work on the back your ass first
is your girl okay right that's not
saying if she's arching her back and
she's posing on a log naked shoe girl I
don't trust those pictures I think
they're fake well it does there are some
of those pictures well if you got
catfished make this way better you gotta
do something
nothing's right now you're in the
shallow end I'm doing stuff so you're in
the shower and holding busy [ __ ] pool
you copy now let me ask you this about
her birthday this weekend that's why my
mom could be all due respect it could be
my mom's funeral
and I'd be like I'm getting laid after
this this little speech my that's
intense your mom's birthday kept you
from basically so you haven't been on a
date yet a plan and stuff all this times
work the big chin you don't have any
matches or anything no no it's pretty
bad I mean it was like he's hopeless so
three weeks try we have a friend we have
a friend man his name a tinder how many
dates has he been on our boy he's been
on tender he's been on [ __ ] thirty
date tonight on seven days he's not
winning any beauty contests yeah no our
friends not [ __ ] he's
have you seen the girls that he dated
though he says they're nice they're hot
yeah
listen dude what are you looking for I
mean are you gonna measure their
cheekbones oh I don't know I see
I smell something that's not bad you do
the fishing up here anytime about the
sushi ate for breakfast
let them fish you up here and see cuz I
was driving your chin I drove here at
offense a 50 year old man and we talked
behind your back I know I saw about
seven or eight girls I can add something
something to do with it I knew though
that's you know at the bus stop that's
right that's real life though that's
dawn tinder hey bro hey I wanna see how
about we make an account for Brian just
for fun wants to see what I do wrong but
I'd like to I'd like to see you don't
want that chin cuz he would kill them I
would I would I would applause that let
me see your account let me see your let
me see and I want to see the girls show
me some cuz Brenda right now we're gonna
go through it and I want to I can
guarantee and I love doing this yeah I
guarantee Brenda and I so what I want to
know is do you want to be in grinder or
what hm and I don't take this as
disrespect at all but hear me on it I
think there's two things going on here
hey you like boys alright and I don't
give a [ __ ] that's actually encouraged
with that sound I think that'd be
awesome
and I'll celebrate the [ __ ] or B we talk
behind your back a little bit about this
might be virgin you virgin oh god I wish
no no I don't mean me and brighter child
or dead soon if I swipe letter to house
so swipe left means you don't like them
and swipe right means you like them and
swipe right swipe up means you super
like them plus wow there's a super I
like your last I like her
Carly oh yeah USC but definitely don't
see their knee can I see more pictures
no that's it oh so click on the picture
once and I might show you some other
pictures if not I'm into flying arms
she's walking away again so I'm gonna
try walking away and looking back
sometimes I'm like what's going on yeah
but like you're picking on the first one
right the very first ones right is she
is she the old one on the right she the
young died beats on the last good
question
it's not as easy as you think I can't
paint her favorite get out oh no
Michelle no no Gabrielle three I'm
swiping right big of lips I'm not mad at
her chin he liked chocolate I've had
tacos before he's afraid of chocolate
yes are you afraid too much I'm not
chocolate
obviously we just found out you're a
sick bastard Wow well think things you
know about Jim 100% I got no no too
crazy oh I got no problem with that
April this is so he'll [ __ ] yes
because either contemplating each each
person Oh hold on this is wifey son her
quote April at twenty nine thirty four
miles away it says definitely not a
player but I do crush a lot hold up the
Big Pun yes super like anal I'm swiping
right what's she cute a dollar yeah not
bad yeah yeah you're either going out
with URI oh oh yeah chris farley is a
wig on okay no okay no it's a disaster
nope reboot done nope nope no no no no
mouth looks like a grouper fish no a
grouper fish she's baked exactly exactly
grouper this dog no I keep going no told
you as a black guy in there no yes for
her come on dude hey Soph reinjure
Harvard chin hate money sounds like fun
she's great oh well this girl has
literally just her hair and and and a
quarter of her eyes showing so we're
gonna definitely um I don't why it hurt
no she do as well coordinator you see
Central Florida well does that mean
she's close she's got a body on her
that's that's honestly by miles so she
has to be somewhere with it like like 50
miles or something
Sonia that I was they're all named up
nope nope nope and dirty in a good way
no yep white nope Wow I hate saying no
to these blurry
she looks like she's moving so I took
this picture as they were running by
listen okay hey listen oh [ __ ] if you're
on tinder and you can't take a [ __ ]
clear picture we can't swipe right let
me see that pictures be click on oh
that's her you know what she looks like
Jeanette does what oh yeah like I think
it was Jim like did you fix you no no I
did I changed no nope just me No Oh
Jenifer know what is she doing here what
are you doing yeah I see it in swiping
right all odds no not a Jennifer we
can't swipe just left us no yeah yeah
left us no I saw you doing right at time
oh you know what that's too much fortune
I would say hell yes free [ __ ]
tattoos tank top miniskirt I Valery's
picture DJ she don't have she's a good
pair little goth girl I'm swiping
bumpkin right read this swipe let me get
on some of this be nice I like hockey
metal watching crime documentaries and
sucking did all things 80 animals [ __ ]
Koreans at over six three again love
sucking dick I live in post audio
engineer rock on PS off sucked you're
dead no no not at all you know me hey
left or right if I like them I laughed
if you don't like them right if you like
them go right but my my fingers all
right all right
if I like them yeah yeah fun with this
one
let me do it hold on
well yes yeah hey bro you better start
waking the [ __ ] up cuz I'm getting
myself right what am i doing barrel fish
get-get-get there's a bunch of belly up
fish all right well no Alexis no no no
yes no no no no yes
I got it I got to see something I like
to see Wow bro you smell like Khaleesi
dragon both right now I didn't yeah your
brother's hot no it's not no nope not
good enough for chin I want to see like
good enough of me like see Wow no way
bro see Brian's a bad one listen I'm
telling you dude your bright lights
muster women Oh like do the most it's
not good what the [ __ ] Jin I'm telling
you right now bro I'm really at the end
of my rope with you I am too a little
bit
I'm at the end of my rope dude so what
makes a marvelous chinder shirt yeah you
are dating her no no that's a mom like
old mom this year that's you can you put
age limits on their chin yeah and what
do like what be careful hold up
what was your stuff what do you think I
made it was it sir there's a first of
all 18 18 to 35 no he got he went 30
above I wouldn't know Brian's clothes
though I'm not trying to be unrealistic
I put 27 to 37 37 you think you think
I've seen say hot 40 girl I just I know
yeah
ha no no huh I've never dated someone I
never dated a girl my age ever at least
how's it been working out for it hey
that's because I'm not looking I'm doing
this for the show you are not if you're
doing this for the show have you been on
a date every goddamn night you ain't
looking what do you mean you ain't
looking cuz you know why if you're
looking harder than anyone I don't see
Oh gay gay [ __ ] you can buy that I mean
you want a guy on top of you
blah you're saying finally I feel the
line you know what happened Brian I were
single and on tinder oh my god you know
the material would have on the show I'd
have to carry around antibiotics I'd
have to carry them around with me you
would come in and there'd be a bowl of
antibiotics like a [ __ ] skittle to
just be I'd be like no did you take
pills Brian I did it anyway so tired so
night their bollocks 24/7 oh my god yes
we'd have a good time she not tender I'm
just gonna go on a date for you guys
whoa well don't go on a date for me go
on a date for you dick hey wait for you
bro I've never had so many people want
me to date some like I think it is time
I get back into dating but I think can I
eat her about it that's the prom
you know what yep your prom but it was
also put a [ __ ] on the pedal stool to
quote it's not how does 40 year old you
doing a pedestal ah be groveling over
every girl if it was you're just not I
don't know I need a little something is
it an energy thing that's going on it
you got mochi bro it might be a little
TV let me see you nuts
future balsa I or League first I'm gonna
get you doing some explosive exercise
that's another ever so that has to be
part of it doesn't exercise
you got a train dude hey gym membership
I talked to my guys box and burn there
we will hook the wheel I'll take it oh
I'm good yeah it's done got chin pick a
time he can go it's done you have nine
o'clock class you're not here 11:30 yeah
they don't have a shower but you know
they do they grow they do in Brentwood I
can't see it I didn't say Brentwood well
you can do after this show either way if
you start working out testosterone
raises after the show confidence all
right I'll hook you up do it you you
need to exercise I know and you need to
you need you'll feel you'll become a
different person you also got to stop
Pino and jump you know what you're like
you like the factored with a shirt on
sixth grade that refuses to take the
shirt off in the pool I was that was
that kid and you were a fat kid that's
what I was saying
now let me finish and here's the thing
it you're gonna spike your test awesome
you can do some explosive exercise
jackoff like I'm gonna believe yep I
want to I want to taking [ __ ] to hand
and I want you to viciously jag off
while you read Nietzsche but listen what
you have with you we have to create some
we have to create some some some
movement in your body here I can't have
you be six four three and not you know
no and it sounds like you got a live
chin god you're not living yeah
sometimes one something emotions going
on we'll get to it it's fine thanks guys
you're lying to us yeah well do its job
what's your take on this MBA from a
girl's perspective what do you think's
going on with chin if you had to you
know this is my favorite section you
just come to yoga class with me I'll
introduce you the girls but I'm not the
intro of girls I don't think I'm the
problem
but because if weif you walked by right
now he ain't ready for it that's what
I'm picking up if she was if she was
actually my type I would be all over but
I have not seen my type in freaking
along cause she ain't out there cuz I'm
not even good you know what you're
looking for MJ you seem very in your
body you take care of yourself you are
in shape yeah and you work out what
everyday um try to I do yoga most every
day yes I'm sorry yeah and you were a
dancer oh there you go I was like wait
it's you and you don't like us and we're
dancers what she's dancer she has all
this energy
are you dating someone right now um I'm
more focused on school right what's up
Rob are you I'm 23
she's 23 she has more dick headed her
way to making imagine she had an awards
or situations that she could literally
text like yo [ __ ] here now that's what
I'm saying who everybody was dick she
she has so much dick over he has shade
29 when she wants but she doesn't want
one right now
no she's not super into you never know
DJ has on speed she can do she can it's
like a bad signal there's no bad signal
for each in you put up a bad signal all
these hot chicks aren't flocking
talking to two guys who probably have
been have been in the game a long time
and who don't go you go home without
without the touch of a feeling you never
have 10,000 plus you guys he doesn't me
are so different in so many different
but that there's no reason maybe but I
would suggest that what's holding you
back is fear and something name oh okay
I'm just not like super crazy about
dating right now
mmm yeah I'm gonna die with your cat
yeah yeah I something's going on and
Plus hey I want you to that working out
then we'll come could you guys do like
one-night stands and then like say you
were both single how were you guys with
one-night stands are you guys cool with
it no problem bro one-night stand
yeah we're in the Hall of Fame for one
night me I actually feel like [ __ ] I
feel terrible let me tell you a story
there is a girl I was with my buddy and
we were in the same room and apparently
my buddy I didn't I didn't know the girl
but my buddy was she was his smoke show
he was appalled that I quote unquote
went down on her I was like what what
you bit up your a Paul by that I'll
[ __ ] live down there you didn't even
know her that's right I sure didn't know
her I had no idea who she was
I'm an animal Jake I'm gonna have two
better guys to help you out here yeah
what you got - hey man that's too
scarred off that my dick has barnacles
on it man it's all scarred up we're like
we're cow Redken of chicks man we got to
cal ripken - that's right and then you
got the young NJ here more like me right
now she's nothing look at me right now
you and Emily could not be further apart
school nothing dating right now no no no
no obviously she is has anyone she wants
23 though I'm on a different but you're
a handsome guy I'm so confused you
telling me yeah somebody if I really
wanted to date like someone that's
actually kind of attractive right now
you ain't doing [ __ ] you just you know
he doesn't and it's okay
you're just afraid and sometimes we're
afraid and that's right Oh what
rejection
yeah or just a fair bit if I was afraid
of rejection I would even go on this
you've done 30 swipes in seven more than
30 by now
yeah cuz me and Brian jump is rockin
Swagelok yeah you you you we did about
100 for you there's all yeah there's
only so many things are gonna do if
that's not matching what do you do
what was your three-year like what do
you guys go out on dates was it more
like home just live together like what
are you looking for I really live
together
will you have you at the time no okay do
you feel confident now do you feel
confident to go on a date with like a
supermodel or Victoria's Secret girl I
honestly wouldn't even match up with a
supermodel we're just two personalities
but I mean a girl it's funny yeah so are
you looking for someone that likes eater
like foodie or I mean what kind of
foodies are good do you like to travel
you like to [ __ ] explore when we're
on the road you know that's travel that
was with you
you've been Australia Dublin London
you've been all over yeah that's not sim
sister I mean you go all over with me
and do we have time to do anything no
yeah you like to have sex outside how
talk I thought this seemed an easy case
to crack
I thought Schindler was gonna he's like
if you keep just [ __ ] ginger like I'm
you're gonna come in here just exhausted
like this what happened veins like dude
I met this [ __ ] [ __ ] now and she I
had to do meth I get it I get it she
came a drunk brother it's better for the
audience that I'm not getting a like
hooked up I think it looks better
I do you do I think it's better for them
the guys that don't get hooked up on
tinder hey bro I think you got a strange
logic here okay I actually feel good
about it if you do if I hooked up right
oh wow you're living in a fantasy bro
now if you feel good baby it's yeah you
guys just think differently you know
we're putting pressure on yeah maybe
I've been acting a long time pretty good
at reading human behavior yeah tell me
I'm gonna have to say that there's
something else going on and that's out
there something else get something else
Brian besides being gay and I don't care
but I think I'm ever the bit my feeling
is that it's it's right now it's new
territory and it's a little awkward for
you right hold on
oh you don't think I've dated plenty of
times in my own not a lot neither you
have I just think it's been a while that
when I freakin my ex-girlfriend she's
hot she what are you talking about wait
she was hot a lot of the best friends
Sam no
best friends you guys seem like best
friends that was the first time I saw
her like here's the thing for me I feel
like you're an intelligent handsome guy
with with something the process though
so I'm good job having trouble
understanding why you're not interested
but maybe you're just not physically
into it right now
physically intimate maybe you just don't
have a sex drive right now for whatever
reason no you guys mentioned that before
but I don't think it's that either man
like if you start working out like we
want it more than he does yeah that's
what it is yeah you guys want a couple
one you guys want the perverts
boned out every chicken that that's
right there you go that's right because
we're a couple one to me that's fine
that's fine but at least take some
swings my father by the way
when I I've had conversations with him
and that guy that guy had said to me I
was just very picky I've already said
you're not picky I was picky I was like
ah
picky you know and I had a conversation
I like did you put it down he's like no
never really did was kind of a one-girl
so some guys are are you a one-to-one
girl type of guy chin I've never like
messed around or anything yeah were you
raised your right very strict but you
guys very Christian even to her break up
why not we have like time off I didn't
cheat until we were absent because of
lack of options no because you guys are
always faithful as their options no
there's nothing that specific moments
you and I will tell you real messed up
story but during that time I wanted to
hook up with another girl who happened
to be my friend's cousin and me and my
girlfriend want to break okay and I
actually went to the girl's house got
really close to it and that I couldn't
do it that's just much weird
well oh you don't want to have anyone so
feel yes which is a good trait see you
guys are not like that guy I came a
little bit like that I would say Brian's
less known I know I understand feeling
bad or like being in love with the
person still no I felt bad for my
girlfriend at the time that actually
broke up with at the time I felt bad
that I was why did you guys break up cuz
we just weren't this breakup with her
she broke up with me the first time that
I broke up with the whole thing in the
end so I'm the one that ended the entire
relationship tell you what man I feel
like we're trying to solve the [ __ ]
theory of everything right now it's all
different people are different it's all
emotional I
never even been in kind of guys like to
do like I did when I stand twice in my
life and I felt crappy it wasn't worth
it for me
why you felt used I felt like as soon as
it was over she's in my bed I just want
her to get out of my bed there's no
dryer day never that so I at the time I
would happen I had the second time a
friend come the doors like I don't want
something to do yeah I just I don't know
what's gonna help somebody it's like
you're speaking to me
but excuse me sir dating again happy
yeah it's cool to date so I'm like ah
she won't be open to dating again so
that's why I'm even doing all this stuff
before I wasn't like a priority of mine
it wasn't really a priority but it'd be
a nice supplement you know but you know
I don't want you to die off 15 with
three cats how focused are you when you
guys are in a relationship like in the
beginning I've never not had girls or
women are like yeah are like it's like
it's like it's like a shark swimming
debris yes the greatest like right just
different like make it a beautiful naked
girl that you get every what what yeah
it's hey how about this what stay alive
for happy you know Picasso said a man
does everything for a woman including
the noise games besides bowls and
[ __ ] you know goes to war women are a
driving force I would imagine but you
already that can make you unfocused chin
I know if I'm in a relationship I
usually end up being like like if
something bad goes on the relationship
it screws with me so I can't finish lost
that they don't want to fire you I know
my loss for words you know anything I'm
being real here you're super skeptical
of their nose so you know how like I
don't know if you know tinder works but
you can link it up with your Instagram
people do you're supposed to do that
link it up in the entry makes sense
because my Instagram is basically tinder
I'll tell you right now if you go to my
tinder and you go look at so that if you
push the photo up if you're interested
in the person you'll see all the posts
on Instagram okay all my posts are about
gender and dating and with hundreds of
comments about yeah that's also I think
honestly what MJ
if you knew that you're gonna be
possibly dating a guy that's going to be
a part of
show that my talk about you would you do
it if you're on tinder I personally
wouldn't but girls do that for the
bachelor and bachelorette but but also
you're not a scumbag you're not gonna
come on here and be like I don't know
man last night me and Rebecca got it on
I took her to sushi then we went anal
I'm just his possible that that might be
but I gotta piss so hard I'm at a loss
for words
yeah well you know yeah and it will
figure it out it's all right dude we got
this so nice the switch in your shirt I
hate how about listen chill I'm trying
to make money I do to him you know Jim
no no I got I swear to God I talked to
Glendon box actually beat on the big
brown breakdown am I freaking out so
we'll talk then however I literally I
think it's good for listeners cuz you
know Brian are doing I think you but to
go on a journey with you because there's
a lot of our listeners there's a lot of
single males out there like [ __ ] man we
need help - I'm telling they're like
chinder I mean Gina
I've got everything goin on it's all
good it's like it's like he's a baseball
guy and wants to be a home run hitter
yeah you got marked with Greiner Barry
Bonds telling you how to hit the goddamn
ball you not listen yeah
you're not taking swings but you guys
are no tinder let's go out let's go out
and then do go out yeah find some girls
outside or just get on the road or
Instagram cancellations it's weird and
you gotta be there for like 10 hours
swiping it's like I think it's lame yeah
you're talking at me you're not talking
to her
it'll be like saying is I'd like to come
to your party but I gotta get my car
wash and there it's gonna take the
weekend yeah I gotta get my gather my
goddamn thoughts and figure out what to
do a check how dare you compare yourself
to NJ wave she's [ __ ] tight under
lawyers didn't everyone who's a sis
obviously obviously I'm saying that but
with all or off you can have
doing sceetos but all our options she
doesn't want anyone that's what I'm
talking about as she has her compare
them to us her own events we've got
Corinna bad bro we're in a very minute
on your finger um my dog everybody left
I'm so bad my dog reached up for the
ball and bit my finger by accident and
so I put the dog down they said yep and
and got a tetanus shot and then and then
killed my other dog because he needed to
stand because I didn't like his react
just shield alpha there wasn't I didn't
get the compassion out here yeah yeah
what do you got Jim all right MJ just
showed me this actually Equifax the
credit card or the credit reporting
agency yeah that's an it was hacked yep
and over 143 million Americans Social
Security numbers dates of birth names
addresses have been stolen look at
everything enough everything how do you
know if you're affected by that check
your credit report really see if it's
all jacked up all of a sudden god damn
it yeah well hopefully our boy Paul with
my [ __ ] gets cry get you know you got to
change credit cards somebody steals it
somebody stole my credit card I remember
I saw him do it I was like why is it
Robin he's an uber guy I was like in
Montreal is like well I was taking my
credit card and running it back I heard
my cue and say he changes his credit
card every month that's good credit card
fraud yeah a lot of people had it
successfully I know change the credit
cards every month or three months yeah
that makes sense too much hassle on it
too much husband also I wait till my
gets stolen and then even then I'm like
the plug it to it yeah yeah Tyrese so
Dwayne Johnson has been announcing on
his Instagram that he's signed a deal a
brand new deal for something and with
the Hobbs move his character in Fast and
Furious yeah okay so it's a what do you
call it when they branch out to another
franchise it's on the same franchise
with something uh it's a spin-off
spinoff there you go so the spin-off
he's he kind of like announced it on his
Instagram
Tyrese message to him saying
well this is uh Dwayne Johnson saying
blah blah trailer where a lot of deals
are made so they had this deal done and
then Tyrese wrote this thing on his
comments saying if you move forward with
that Hobbs movie you'll have purposely
ignored the heart - um I had in my
sprint - I don't want to hear from you
and so the until you remember what we
talked about I'm on your timeline
because you're not responding me to my
text messages hashtag fast family is
just that oh hey yeah hard - hard moment
you sent me that you text if you tweet
that to everybody which is this guy
Theresa yeah I don't know I'm sorry but
also Fast and Furious family you've had
how many of them also it's rock he's by
far the biggest star of the entire thing
so it's a man once you have your spinoff
if you're a true friend
hey but what about all this all of us
brother off me how many Miller there are
you see mom I guarantee I'm wrong I'm
the biggest movie star in the world come
on
I'll figure out a part for you maybe no
what are you talking about what does
that mean so what is he saying so in
other words if you do a spin-off of Fast
and the Furious that would be a betrayal
that's what he's saying that's not how
this our horse no horse
it's like when Brian a spin-off didn't
write me into it I don't carry why did
you bring that up I do something right
it looks like you've been on the
Goldbergs and gold birds on and all
right it's like you know you don't any
shine my way but again I'm not Tyreese
it's like you're the rock of comedy you
won't let me get my beak that's crazy
talk man I mean I would never
Brian ignores my tech she'll see me
freaking out siren damn it I'd love to
get you on the Goldbergs oh I never do
it that's very weird of tires to do that
must be some serious [ __ ] to go on
Instagram these high priest goes on
Instagram a lot but to reach out about a
personal issue any friend you've ever
had that reached out on Instagram and
don't have friends like that I don't
have friends like that like D'Elia make
fun of me on Instagram will make fun
each other but nothing serious
do you imagine if hey be on Instagram
yeah I mean come on
yeah you guys well he did rose roasted
me you both roasted me on that video I
did about Via Veneto you know let me
walk meanwhile but I think Chris brought
a thing or this is great ok like this is
a great video that's where it
something's going on more than there
deeper than just a spin-off yeah yeah
they had a heart-to-heart and Teresa's
sprinter so you know I'm sorry can I
just say that so Teresa I don't know
Teresa I don't know em but I also feel
like he's making this about himself like
you're also it's also like you're
bringing us into this weird thing like
we had a heart-to-heart moment if you're
gonna ignore that like hey dude
Gus there's very air family rocks gone
oh oh sorry but I can but I think you're
confused too I'm the rock I'm the
biggest action when we start in the war
by high-speed actor in the world
I was it I think it famous from The Fast
and Furious franchise he unfollowed
Terry's on social media he's not refined
to his tax I serious about threatening
him with sassy talkin Israel make a
difference your thoughts here's who died
and made Tyreese the fast family
gatekeeper I swear his ego is nauseating
I've listened to Tyreese episodes I've
listened I don't know but I've listened
to his Instagram like bring up his
Instagram for a second because it is
very I'm sure he's a good guy and I
really believe I don't know I don't know
seems like a good guy but this is also
he also seems a tad and that he's an
actor though not even that I don't know
what the word is
I don't know well to in himself Jesus
Christ what does that Jen use his like
like he'll say he's so proud of you bro
when he's talking about um ya know just
go down no girl let's see what that
video is about there no it was a picture
of him though did not this one yeah that
one
believe believe believe following you
folks out there looks tired
who's feeling the same
things that I'm feeling as I'm
recovering still as long as two people
stand together in faith in the purest
form of faith and you believe you
believe you believe it happen I believe
I'd be married married happily married
the Morpho you're sad he's looking off
in the distance right I believe that I
would buy a home Liat chain in ten years
leech in after the tinder segment
English [ __ ] pirates you see what I mean
see what happens Chen when you say no
all these dates yeah no you guys he that
looks worse for wear cousin Joshua keeps
crawling down he's crawling out I need
one more video well there is a sultan a
sense of humor probably but he's also
he's actually sound pretty serious
I need another video gone please keep
going alright I want to see what the
last one
I'm add a little music so he's doing a
video it's nothing okay let's see what
else you see what I mean like okay dude
[Music]
[Music]
so go okay give me one more chin doesn't
good stuff the video him inside he's a
good guy but you know I think he's like
that they're like there's just a lot of
this stuff where it's just you know
y'all make sure y'all tone in tonight
and watch snowfall there's nothing else
really matters right now I'm about to
tune in nothing else matters
I never watch TV and I'm hooked on this
show shout out to my man chance at this
friends video continuing to push south
central lay on the map if y'all don't
know what the TV show is about it's
about when crack cocaine took over LA
there is a good shot gives down on that
facts FX can't highest-rated show on FX
they've already been renewed for a
second season
and they're killing me welcome mo for
snowfall keep da yeah give me one more
God we sure know what I'm being saying
go dick I'm gonna continue to use my
god-given stage and platform to speak on
topics issues politics that most people
are literally afraid to speak on and the
midst of all of this stuff that's
happening which is very biblical okay
it is amazing to me that I've now the
smart ones are out here looking at the
metaphor of where everything was so
about racism and bigotry and what
happened is Shara Vail and all these
other issues Sharla's over but we're
reminded of the human spirit and more
importantly the human race I'm not mad
at this black white like I said well I
say these Diaries still recovering when
you were stuck I just not but still
recovering you just yes like I said he's
a I know but why type good yeah I just
say Brendan working out yeah you know
where it is he's a really good person I
really think like oh I'm sure I'd really
like him there are some people and I
have friends like this that they they
think whatever they say has grave
significance and if you actually listen
to the words it's not that
significant but for him in it but his
followers you know young father yes
eight point eight million followers to
talk about this positive guy I like he's
a have some influence I like you gotta
like him yeah it's funny no no one is
super sad yeah wow what a sketch I liked
appreciate I'll hit on the rock though
not so Roxanne do spin-offs cuz any give
a [ __ ] about fast and furious 19 yeah
what else you got yeah and posting that
ways everyone knows you don't do that
Tyrese Geico got some real money for
sure
yeah oh my no youngest by now
go ahead Adrian Drona probably Jim
Broner was in Las Vegas and there's a
videotape of him getting in an argument
with the girl no
so he's arguing with her and then he
sorts of sort of pushes her away some
guys walking towards him and he just
clocks on the mouse and then did you see
his post on Instagram today no good
agent brownish Instagram for me today
this is scary [ __ ] cuz he's had some
suicidal thoughts before oh he says I
want help right no just one I wish he
said I want help who uh if I if I wasn't
here I wonder will they feel the same
like oh that that one that go up to this
last one no no goes who will come talk
to me
so he's basically crying out for help
you haven't slept in two days he's he's
just mentally unstable yeah that's maybe
but also to keep people who no no no
people I mean could be a little bit I
don't think you can chalk it up ties
it's always weird people try their stuff
but I think he's just an emotional dude
but also people are actually commit
suicide don't give these warnings like
he's literally looking for help yeah
people commit suicide err the pretty
games friends help him man he needs help
but what so so the guy was walking
toward him that was the guy walking
toward him to get involved no it was he
saying something gently tell her but he
pushes a girl and then they're walking
lesson stripping you see him its aging
Broner for God's sakes knocks the dude I
can throw the right hand you think
so that's him just taking pictures with
the crowd
I like Adrian brother he's screwed now
though and then it's not just lost to
[ __ ] Mikey Garcia is this him arguing
with the girl he's with he pushes her
she but it seems like she's trying to
grab him he's just like Amy alone so he
pushes her cuz she's grabbing him
he seen it all like that trying to get
away which I don't Lucille's guilt off
for me
and then here it's hard to see you can
hear it though yeah so someone just gets
punched in the face so it looks like he
smacks the dude out for no reason yeah
he's upset or the guys coming at him
he's screwed now go and that's the guy
on the ground
it's a bomber cuz I think if you I
guarantee if you were the one that Mikey
Garcia fight you don't see this
happening but that Mike Garcia fight was
such a fork in the road for him and
Mikey Garcia it's like whoever won that
went this way whoever didn't went this
way yeah so for agent bronan I keeps
flashy he's actually when he's actually
the second biggest african-american draw
behind 40 Mayweather haploids out
yeah because Adrien Broner is one of
those guys who he like was hip to
WorldStarHipHop and Instagram and social
media before most people so he got
really famous from that and he's a good
talker and talked about [ __ ] and then he
can kind of back it up but don't even
lose fight it's over so now this it's
just a bummer I thought I mean Mike
Garcia fight was a terrible plan for him
I thought it was mismanaged poorly he
should not been fun because Marc you're
a bad match on a horrible metric why the
[ __ ] monster yeah Mike FC cuz thing
by agent Broner is I think he's too
small for the division my curse even
came up you know Mike Geary sees a guy
who his fundamentals are so good he's a
world champion multi world world class
in different weight classes too but
Adrien Broner just he's always had
discipline issues Oh fighting a
technician like Mike you guys just huh
that's a bummer
Wow definitely and he's done this stuff
before he's had suicide talks before and
then Floyd Mayweather reached out to him
carry on sir this is a happier everyone
sent me this even MJ is a tinder date
that went wrong so this girl had a date
with this guy ended up needing to take a
dump
badly so she went into this restroom
took a dump blew it up it wouldn't flush
oh no it wouldn't flush so she panicked
oh she pulled it out pull it out and
then tried to throw it out the window
trying to [ __ ] out the window
she tried to tell me Tomer is it no I'm
out the window yeah he was trying he's
trying to throw the kid no he was he
open the window was airing it out
she took pieces of [ __ ] and threw it out
the one cause it wouldn't flush you
don't want him put the log what happens
like down but she threw it out and then
the way his window is it fell on the
bottom pane it didn't go outside it
actually fell on the window she played
you could see it right there so she's
like an amateur gymnast and she figured
she could find a way to get over there
she's got a face full of [ __ ] and these
guys have to firefighters had to take
her out yeah oh my god and their [ __ ] is
oh hey Barry what's the worst you can
happen well you take the [ __ ] and the
sighted won't flush so you take the logs
thrown out the window but they get stuck
then you try to grab them to get stuck
in the window yeah so I had this [ __ ] I
took a [ __ ] I picked it up out of the
bush to throw it away and then it landed
on this on the pits right now I'm stuck
with my face in the [ __ ] like worst date
ever worst night for you ever boyfriends
Oh Jordan there and I want you not all
of us everywhere including across the
Atlantic Ocean know about it we all know
about it oh my god that's horrible
he started a GoFundMe page because he
had to break his window for $400 it cost
to fix it and he raised up to like
thousand 70 euros this poor thing
to be tough for that girl to another day
and I don't know do you know what she
looks like no they wouldn't do that to
her I don't think they would I hope not
but
I'm so bunched up right now first I feel
claustrophobic she's stuck upside down
I've got a girl blow up my toilet is
just yesterday mother me too me too I
had to wait for ten minutes before I
could stop dry-heaving and then I had
sex with her oh that really will shut me
down
I just feel sorry I ate clams
I feel eggy know what else you got chin
have you guys seen the demon goat No
oh my god oh my god
so I thought it was fake but it made Fox
News which I don't know what that means
but here's a video of it she is hideous
it looks like a banner holy the mouse
moving oh my god it looks like a goat
with a touch of the dam I ain't eating
eating stand looks looks like a gargoyle
yeah thanks guys
he's just foreign poor little bunny
things all deformed yeah you gotta put
them down well I think that's have a
human face
nothing's scary yeah man look at that I
guess we came from goats notice yet - um
nothing much china plans to ban fossil
fuel cars entirely the other stopping
the production of fossil fuel cards hey
um that's a Oh see you China that's
amazing
France is doing it in 2040 to stop
selling fossil fuel cars what's that
France yeah is gonna stop selling fossil
fuel cars by 2040 damn 2040 look forward
to that yeah Jesus Christ nice gray I'll
tell you what when cars 30 years
we're over this we're over actually 23
and 20 years yeah is that it - nakorn
English quarter century
we're thing of stopping our plan is
these things take a long time uh-huh
buddy was an interesting one
yeah anyway yes yeah so now what else I
was gonna do a little uh stop it here's
my dropping knowledge
dropping knowledge so I thought this
interesting statistic marital rape how
do you define marital rape well let's
get ready kind of moaning right
well that's no I'm just kidding 53
countries up until 2000 so that's
horrible that was the idea right in 53
countries out of the 194 countries in
the world I think it is 53 never didn't
have any laws against marital rape is
crazy bhai is right
yeah well it's a weird it's not that
weird so even if the charm you don't
want to have sexual intercourse and you
force yourself on yeah so the idea would
be also that remember rape for a long
time was considered fun no I don't know
where your girls drop me no it was
considered like a crime against the man
just to not be no no to hell not let him
finish you know it was a crime against
the man because you were committing a
crime against his property and it wasn't
until recently that's that's like maybe
it was Middle East not it was actually
in it was a European thing what about
here well even here I mean until like
you know we've always had in light more
enlightened laws in terms of rape but
for the most part what I'm saying is
that it was always considered you know a
crime rape was a woman was your property
you owned her sexually right and then if
somebody raped her they had to pay you
know they had to pay the man for the
event so even in the book of Deuteronomy
which is the Old Testament which is the
Jewish Bible in the book of Deuteronomy
and we talk about the Quran we talk
about like what religion says a lot of
stuff is it open for interpretation but
in the book of Deuteronomy
when a man Tate rapes a woman what
happens is there's a whole ritual which
is the family must that the man must pay
the father fifty shekels or whatever it
is a certain amount of silver and as a
result he then has to marry that woman
and that woman becomes his property now
Jesus and still in some countries that's
still super custom the custom would be
you raped my daughter well instead of
killing you you now have to marry her so
some guys in those
as we go I like her I'm gonna rape her
and make her mine and so you can see
I'll find loopholes ha bye here you'll
find Ubuntu move on bags and find some
Lube my cousin believe in 50 in 2006 it
was still you know 2006 it was still
kind of there was no law against us
eventually raping your wife because it
was like it's your wife okay can can
guys technically be raped some guys say
it I'll see oh yeah guys in the bus
however but I'm saying can females right
guys did you see some guys I mean and
they've won in court where they say they
got raped that's that guy can't be my
friend
unless he's paralyzed and even then come
on dude
that is strange I don't know I feel that
word no I don't I don't know how you get
a wet noodle into and I have a needle
like how do you do that like it's it's
hard to you know come on I mean Rick I
can't you get me hard well right yeah I
mean right I don't know man this is a
question I don't know how it works you
tell me where you gonna be
but then that's where we lose every fan
first yeah you're right for offending
everybody I had a better driving
knowledge but I'll do it tomorrow
I had a really good one actually safer
tomorrow brother well uh I'm gonna be in
Madison Wisconsin you guys the 21st 22nd
23rd at comedy on state get your tickets
at tea fat K then helium comedy club in
Philadelphia
I love 20 29 30 can't wait just go do
comedy at The Improv um I am you know
I'm gonna tell me where you're gonna be
this Thursday I'm just content cops 14th
they've just released more tickets they
released my comps that's the only
tickets left
Cobb's this thursday night chief at
kake.com for the few remaining
tickets and then the following Friday I
am in Long Beach California at the Laugh
Factory great club tea factory calm this
Thursday San Francisco next Friday Long
Beach get tickets right now this is the
photic kid we're out